En este video vamos a orientarnos sobre los
diferentes tipos de estudios que podrías analizar
estadísticamente o estudios estadísticos. En
primer lugar es bueno diferenciar un experimento
de un estudio observacional. Te invito a que
pauses el video y pienses en cuál crees que sea
la diferencia entre un experimento y un estudio
observacional. Bueno, es posible que ya estés
familiarizado con los experimentos en donde
tenemos una hipótesis que plantea que si le
haces algo a un grupo, éste podría tener algún
tipo de impacto estadísticamente significativo
comparado con otro grupo en el que no lo hiciste.
Y, en general, tendrías razón, eso es lo que
entendemos cuando hablamos de un experimento. En
un experimento agrupamos activamente a personas o
cosas en un grupo de control y lo comparamos con
un grupo que recibe un tratamiento. En el grupo
de tratamiento vamos a seleccionar personas
al azar y les vamos a administrar algo -quizá
un nuevo tipo de medicamento-, así que en el
grupo de tratamiento sus integrantes recibirán
la medicación; mientras que a las personas que
elegimos al azar para estar en el grupo de control
se les administra un placebo -que quizás sea una
píldora que se parece a la medicación, pero que
realmente no hace nada-, luego esperas un tiempo
y analizas si hay una diferencia estadísticamente
significativa entre el grupo de tratamiento en
promedio y el grupo de control. Entonces eso
es lo que hace un experimento: es una especie de
acto de clasificación para averiguar si algún tipo
de estímulo es capaz de mostrar una diferencia;
mientras que en un estudio observacional no se
organiza activamente en grupos, en su lugar
sólo recopilas datos y ves si puedes obtener
algunas ideas de esos datos. Podrías decir "Está
bien, tengo los datos de una población aquí,
¿puedo presentar algunas estadísticas que
sean indicativas de la población?". Tal vez
sólo quieras ver los promedios o tal vez quieras
encontrar alguna correlación entre las variables,
pero incluso cuando hablamos de un estudio
observacional existen diferentes tipos,
según el tipo de datos que estemos viendo: si los
datos son retrospectivos, prospectivos o son datos
que estamos recopilando ahora, con base en lo que
la gente piensa o dice en este momento. Entonces,
si estamos pensando en un estudio observacional
que analiza datos pasados, y me imagino haciendo
algo como esto en Khan Academy, donde podríamos
ver el uso de Khan Academy a lo largo del tiempo.
Tenemos estas cosas en los registros de nuestro
servidor, y podemos hacer algunos análisis allí.
Tal vez podamos analizar y decir que, en promedio,
los estudiantes pasaron dos horas al mes en Khan
Academy durante 2019. Serían datos pasados, y ese
tipo de estudio observacional se llamaría estudio
retrospectivo; "retro" se refiere al pasado,
"espectivo" se refiere a observar. Entonces
el estudio observacional retrospectivo tomaría
muestras de datos pasados para obtener algunas
ideas. Ahora puedes imaginar que podemos tener
lo contrario. ¿Qué pasa si estamos tratando de
observar cosas en el futuro? Bueno, aquí puedes
tomar una muestra de personas que crees que son
indicativas de una población y es posible que
desees realizar un seguimiento de sus datos,
así que incluso podrías considerar que son
datos futuros, por lo tanto, eliges el grupo,
la muestra con anticipación y luego realizas un
seguimiento de sus datos a lo largo del tiempo.
Voy a dibujar estas pequeñas flechas que indican
que estás rastreando sus datos, y luego verás lo
que sucede. Por ejemplo, podrías seleccionar
una muestra aleatoria de 100 mujeres y quieres
averiguar cuántos huevos consumen en promedio por
día durante el próximo año. Bueno, lo que harías
es seleccionar a esas personas y luego rastrear
esos datos para cada una de ellas todos los días,
y luego, una vez que tengas los datos al final del
estudio, podrás ver cuáles son esos promedios o
también puedes darle seguimiento mientras recopilas
estos datos. Y puedes imaginar cómo se llama esto,
en lugar de retrospectiva, ahora miramos hacia el
futuro, por lo tanto es un estudio observacional
prospectivo. Por último, pero no menos importante,
algunos de ustedes probablemente están pensando en
"¿Qué pasa si estamos haciendo algo ahora,
si salimos y encuestamos a un de personas y
preguntamos cuántos huevos comiste hoy o por
quién vas a votar? ¿Cómo podríamos llamar a
eso?" Es tentador llamarlo de alguna manera
con un prefijo y luego utilizar "espectivo",
de manera que todo coincida; pero resulta que la
terminología que suelen utilizar los estadísticos
es una encuesta por muestreo, que tomas una
muestra aleatoria de los individuos de la
población que te interesa y los entrevistas ahora
mismo, haciéndoles algunas preguntas u observando
algunos datos sobre ellos en este momento. Hasta
aquí dejamos este tema. Este video es sólo para
darte un poco de vocabulario y de taxonomía
sobre los tipos de estudio que verás en general,
lo cual es especialmente útil cuando estás
explorando el mundo de la estadística.